welcome my name is rob sanders i'm a
course instructor at simplylearn
so we're going to talk about the types
of seo now
so if we want to rank for a particular
keyword on google
we're going to have to apply search
engine optimization
and so there's two strategies to search
engine optimization
on-page seo and off-page seo so first
we're going to talk about
on-page seo so on-page seo is
nothing more than optimizing your own
website
and so when we say optimizing your own
website there's certain elements
on your website and on your web pages
that we need to take into account and so
some of those elements
are headers meta descriptions title tags
linking so all of those elements are
something we can control
as an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on google
and before we do anything with our
website
the first thing we need to do is
understand
what keywords we want to rank for in
order to understand what keywords we
want to rank for
we need to do keyword research and if
you do anything in seo
keyword research is the most important
activity that's the most important thing
you can do for seo
and why do i say it's the most important
because you need to understand
if you choose a keyword that you want to
rank for you need to understand
how much traffic you're gonna get from
that keyword if you're ranked
organically say number one on google so
how much traffic will you get
if you're ranked number one on google so
you need to understand what the volume
is
and then number two we need to
understand what the competition is for
that keyword that you want to rank for
so if you choose a keyword and there's
not much competition for it
then chances are you can rank for that
keyword
for a web page on your website quicker
than say
a keyword that has a lot of competition
so we need to understand those two basic
factors volume and competition before we
choose a keyword
and it's it's simply the practice of
going through
the motions of getting your volume and
getting your competition
data so you can choose the keywords you
want and then once you choose the
keywords you want
then you can go and apply on page seo
you can change the title tag the meta
descriptions
the headers all those elements can be
changed but first
you need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for
are how much traffic you can get or the
search volume
how much competition there is for that
keyword and of course
relevancy okay you need to be able to
choose a keyword
that's relevant to the web page you're
trying to rank for
and so let me show you example how to go
through this so the first thing we want
to do
is we want to use a tool and the tool i
would recommend
is google keyword planner and why do i
choose google keyword planner because
if we're trying to rank on google.com or
google search engine
we want to be able to get the data right
from the source so google is going to be
able to give us information about
how much volume a keyword has and how
much competition it has
so let me show you an example so if i
want to use google's keyword planner and
i want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist
then i'm going to type that keyword into
google's keyword planner and what google
is going to do
is they're going to give me some trends
about
how much volume this particular keyword
gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword i can
see
that there are trends that that appear
for both desktop and
mobile so mobile is important because
people
start their search process a lot of
times on their mobile device
so we want to be able to get data from
mobile as well as desktop
and so we could see a trend here that
for each particular month
over the last 12 months we can see how
much volume
this particular keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist
gets per month and so on average
on average over the past 12 months i
could see how to become a digital
marketing specialist
is averages 30 searches a month
and this is on google.com and so google
gives us the volume
what they also give us is the
competition and so here i can see
google says for that particular keyword
the competition
is medium and so in the google's keyword
planner what they also do is give me
other
relevant keywords that i might think
about optimizing for
because you don't want to optimize for
just one keyword
so how to become a digital marketing
specialist they're gonna also offer up
other types of keywords that are
relevant so just digital marketing
specialist
social media marketing specialist so for
those keywords
i can see the volume so for example
digital marketing specialist
i can see the average volume is 1 000
per month
on average over the last 12 months i can
also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords i can see
the search volume being high
like digital marketing course at 2 900
per month but also the competition is
high
and so what i would recommend as a best
practice is to collect
all your relevant keywords okay and put
all your relevant keywords
in a spreadsheet and when you put all
these relevant keywords in a spreadsheet
you want to
get the data on those keywords and the
data i'm referring to
is the volume and competition so in this
case we have volume from google planner
google's keyword planner and i have
competition from google's keyword
planner
and so if i go into a spreadsheet and i
put all that information in here
i'm going to be able to see the volume
and competition and so that's important
however one thing to note here is that
google's keyword planner
if we go back just gives us low medium
and high
and if i want to compare numbers to
numbers
maybe i want to be able to get exactly
the competition number for the keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist
what i can do is go into google and i
can type in that keyword
so if i type in the keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
i can see there's 76 million results
so i could see 76 million results 76.1
actually and for the keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
now that's a whole lot of results for
this particular keyword
especially when the volume is only 30
uh per month on average and so what i
want to do is get a
more clear picture of the competition
and so what you could actually do is
type in the syntax
all in title and then colon and then
your keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist
and when i do that i get a different
result here i can see
only 136 listings
for how to become a digital marketing
specialist
but that's not just 136 that's 136.
with that particular keyword that we
want to rank for
in the title tag okay so the title tag
is what you see
when you type in a keyword or search
query in google search
and the title tag is what you see at the
top
of every search result and so now i can
see
i typed in how to become a digital
marketing specialist with the all in
title
syntax and now i can see every listing
every one of these 136 results
have that particular keyword in it
so i could see every one of them how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and why is that important because now
that tells me i only need to
climb over 136 listings
to rank for that keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist
and so the idea here is you want to get
your volume from google's keyword
planner
but you want to get your competition
from google search and again that's
simply typing in the
the syntax call and title and then your
keyword
in this example how to become a digital
marketing specialist
once you get those two numbers you're
going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for a number of different
keyword queries and these keyword
queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in
and pick the keywords you want to
optimize for and that's important
because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research
so you can be sure of how much traffic
you can get
and how much competition there is those
are two important three important
factors
in starting the process for on-page seo
so again
you want to create content
for say a keyword like digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad
so you want to probably stay away from
broader keywords because broader
keywords
tend to have a lot of volume which is
great but
they may also tend to have a lot of
competition
but that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't
maybe there's more volume than
competition that's what you need to find
out when you do the keyword research you
need to find those keywords that are
relevant
to your content that have a lot of
volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords
then we are free to go in and start
optimizing our web pages for those
keywords and the first place we want to
start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search
how to become a digital marketing
specialist we saw that every one of
these
listings had that keyword in the title
tag and the title tag is important
because that's what
users who use google search see first
when they type in a query and get
results
so they're going to see the title tag so
the title tag is the most
important element for on-page seo it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see
and so ideally when we choose our
keyword we want to make sure that
keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page
relevant for that keyword query so the
idea behind a title tag
it's between 50 and 60 characters and so
we want to make sure we stay
within that limit no more than 60
characters because what happens if it's
beyond that
then google will truncate the title tag
so if i go back to my search
you can see here on this particular
title tag
google truncated it meaning they added
the ellipses
after the title tag because it exceeded
the 60 character limit
so you want to stay within those
character counts and so the title tag is
the first place you should start
when optimizing your website because
when we have the right keyword
in the title tag and somebody types in
that keyword
then chances are it's going to be
relevant they're going to see it and
they're going to click through to your
website
and that's the whole idea behind ranking
we want to get clicks
so that's how the title tag appears so
when you optimize it
you're going to update the title tag and
this is how it shows up it's going to
show up at the top of your listing
okay and it's going to be bigger and
bolder than anything else
google displays so the second thing you
want to optimize
is the meta description and the meta
description is simply just a brief
description
up to 155 i would say about 155 to 60
160 characters but probably no more than
that
and so the meta description is nothing
more than a summary
of the web page itself so if i go back
to
my google search results i see my title
tag
and i see the page that this particular
listing belongs to and underneath that
is where i can see
my meta description so in this
particular keyword query how to become a
digital marketing
specialist i see the meta description an
ultimate guide on how to build a career
in digital marketing and the skills
required to become a digital marketing
specialist
note that it's a well-written meta
description within 155 characters
and it includes the keyword digital
marketing specialist so we're trying to
rank for how to become a digital
marketing specialist
and here you can see become a digital
marketing specialist so there's a lot of
relevancy between
not only the title tag in the keyword
but the meta description in the keyword
so when you're optimizing a keyword you
want to start with the title tag
but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description
and you leave the meta description blank
then you're leaving it to google
to add in copy that they deem relevant
and so for on-page seo we want to take
control
of the copy and we want to optimize it
for the keywords we want to be found for
so the meta description is a powerful
tool at our disposal
it gives us more characters to work with
it gives us more to talk about
so for that particular page and so if
the title tag is only
60 characters maximum it's not a lot of
information
to try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us
in identifying what that page is about
in order to get the click
so the two working in tandem will
hopefully
increase your click-through rates so
when you're found organically
we want to get the click and then the
third element that's important
is the url and url stands for uniform
resource
locator and why is the url so important
because
that's what people see so if i go back
to my search result
how to become a digital marketing
specialist notice that the url
also includes how to become a digital
marketing specialist article
okay so it's very relevant the url is
very relevant
one we can see it in the search results
but two
you know it's relevant to the keyword
query and that's important for the end
user
and google google wants to know hey
is this the page that's relevant to the
user's
query and if it is then this user is
likely going to have
a good x user experience after they
click on the listing
so the url is an element that helps
not only with the click-through rate but
with ranking and having a poor url
structure
doesn't help at all because not only
does google
not recognize the url as being relevant
but the end user
may not want to click on that page given
the
the way the url looks so you want to try
and avoid a poor url structure
so the rule of thumb is this if you
don't understand what the url is
then google is likely not going to
understand what the url is
and so we want to try and keep our url
structures clean
and when i say clean ideally you want to
make sure
that whatever keyword you're trying to
optimize
that's the keyword that's included in
the url
nothing included that is not
understandable
so again going back to our example how
to become a digital marketing
specialist it's very clean the title tag
is the keyword
the meta description is cleanly written
has the keyword
and then the url is the other element
that the end user can see
and that url includes the
keyword in it so after we've done those
three elements
the title tag the meta description and
the url
then we want to start optimizing the
page itself
so ideally when we say optimize the page
itself
the page remember needs to be structured
and when we say structured it needs to
be structured in terms of
you know headers and subheaders and
organized in a
manner in which the end user can read
the article read the content clearly and
concisely
without being confused and so that's the
job of headers
they add they add basically an
organizational structure to the content
and with headers there's a hierarchy so
you have anywhere from
h1 which is the top of the hierarchy to
an h6
and so you're free to use any one of
those headers when building out a page
in order to organize the content
but ideally you probably want to stick
with an h1 or an
h2 because those are at the top of the
hierarchy
and what those do is they actually
stress to google that hey
this header with this particular keyword
in it
is important so if you use an h6 with
the keyword in it
it's telling google hey this is an h6
but it's not
as important so an h1 and an h2 tag
show importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is
so here you can see an h1 is going to be
at the top of the hierarchy so that
means it's going to be bigger and bolder
then you have an h2 which is going to be
bigger and bolder than an h3
but not as big and bold as an h2 so with
headers
not only are you organizing the content
accordingly
but you're also signaling to google how
important
that particular header is and of course
the header
needs to include the keyword we're
trying to rank for
so let's take a look again at that
example so
if we go to how to become a digital
marketing specialist if i click on that
page
i can look at the content and i can see
that there
are headers in here so the headers are
there to
organize the content and that's what we
want we want to be able to organize the
content
and if you look at the other example i'm
showing here
how to become a digital marketing
specialist learning paths explored you
can see that's an h1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market
so that's an h2 and so we're not
stressing to google that that's
more important than h1 but nonetheless
we're stressing at google that it's
important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords
in our headers in order to stress to
google
what's important and also to organize
the content because
google likes content organized okay the
next element we want to focus on
is internal linking and so internal
linking if you remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically
links from one page on your website to
another
and so here we can see on this
particular article
how to become a digital marketing
specialist there's also
links to other pages on
simply learns website and so for this
particular
content it also links to seo specialist
ppc specialist social media marketing
specialist and digital marketing
specialist
so the whole idea behind internal
linking is to link from one page to
another
where it's relevant and in this case
it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about
and so what simply learns doing here is
offering up
other pages on their website that are
relevant to becoming a digital marketing
specialist
and so this is a best practice when
you're optimizing
a web page so you want to be able to
have internal linking on your site and
the whole idea behind internal linking
is it also allows users to navigate
through the site naturally
so when i say naturally they don't
always have to refer back
to the top navigation they can naturally
and seamlessly
go from one relevant article or page to
another
and so that's the whole idea behind link
building and internal link building and
allows google
to identify you know pages that they
want to crawl and index
because they're linked to one another
but it also helps the end user because
it allows the end user to go from one
page to another
and it's signaling to google hey this
particular page is linked to this page
so we're going to also index that page
and so that's the whole important part
of internal linking
it's about the end user experience and
it's about allowing google to
find the pages on your website so they
can crawl them
and index them so you can be ranked for
them and so
also in addition to internal linking we
want to be able to
use natural language and so what do i
mean by
natural language or natural language
processing so what google does
is in terms of natural language
processing
they're looking for the content and the
keyword it needs to be relevant
so when your website is about digital
marketing you don't necessarily want to
rank
or try to rank for the keyword digital
marketing one
it's too broad two there might be some
competition but three
you're probably not going to write
something as broad like digital
marketing so ideally what you want to do
is you want to choose other
relevant related keywords that's going
to be more natural
and so that's what we mean on natural
language processing we want to choose
keywords that are more natural to the
content you're writing so
instead of the keyword digital marketing
maybe we want to talk about
the types of digital marketing or
digital marketing examples
or what is a digital marketing strategy
or how to become a digital marketing
specialist
so those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing
and more relevant to the content because
if you try to rank for the keyword
digital marketing
again it's probably going to be a little
bit broad probably more competition
and not as relevant to your content and
as a result
probably not a good user experience so
think about some other keywords that you
could
optimize and rank for and that goes back
to the keyword research
that's why the keyword research is so
important because it allows us to
identify
other keywords and the natural language
process
what keywords are more relevant for the
content and then
another element on page seo is the
sitemap and so with the sitemap
it's basically a list of all the pages
on your website
and the whole idea of listing all the
pages on your website
in one document is it helps both users
and search engines understand the
structure of your website
so there are two types of site maps one
is an html
site map and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content
at the footer or the bottom of your web
page you probably want to have a link
to sitemap so if somebody clicks on that
site map they're going to be able to see
all the pages on your website structured
in an organized manner
well an xml sitemap and xml is just a
different format
it's designed for crawlers and so the
whole idea
remember is google likes to crawl
content when they crawl
content they bring it back to their
servers and index it and so we want to
be able to create
a sitemap for google or other search
engine crawlers
and so xml is the format so let me show
you example of how that looks
so if i go to simplylearn.com
and simply type in say sitemap.xml
just as an example i'm going to get this
particular page
and this particular page displays two
xml site maps
so these site maps are there for google
to go ahead and crawl and nothing more
than a list of all the pages
on your website and so this is a quick
and easy way for google to get a hold of
all those pages
so that they can index them and that's
the whole idea behind seo
you want to be able to have google index
all the content you want to be found for
for the keywords you want to be found
for
so it all starts with the sitemap so
let's go from
on-page seo which in recap
is basically optimizing certain elements
on your website so that you are relevant
for a particular keyword
and that meant updating the title tag
the meta description
the url the headers choosing the right
keywords to put into the content
having internal linking and also
updating the sitemap
well those are elements that you can do
on your website
so we're going to switch gears and talk
about a different strategy
off-page seo because without on-page or
off-page
you can't have a page ranking so the two
work together
so you can do as much as you want on on
page but you still need off page seo and
you could do all the off page seo you
want but you still need on page
so both of these strategies have to be
in full effect
in order for you to rank so let's now
switch gears to off-page seo
and so off-page seo is simply the
process
of linking or promoting your website
using link building
and so if you remember i talked about
this earlier on
there's two types of links internal and
external linking
and so for on-page seo we used internal
linking
for off-page seo we're going to talk
about external linking
and external linking allows us to
improve our website's recognition or
relevancy
or credibility and why do we want to
improve our relevancy and credibility
and trustworthiness and authority
because we want google to know that our
web page
is trustworthy it is recognized by other
websites
and it is relevant for a particular
keyword and so if we can
do that using off page seo methods then
google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really
off page seo is synonymous with link
building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building
it just comes down to creating a
strategy so again
some of the benefits to off page well we
talked about
you know being credible and
trustworthiness and relevant we need to
do that in order to rank
but there's some other benefits there so
if we have a
link on another credible website then
it's likely
going to increase the traffic to our own
website it also
creates high domain authority and so
what i mean by high domain authority
is if we have basically links to other
web pages
pointing back to us then basically our
domain authority is going to improve and
when our domain authority improves
other websites are going to want to link
to us so the higher
authoritative we are for our website
then other web pages are going to
want to link to us and so the more
external linking we have the higher the
domain authority
so it all starts with linking to other
high
domain authority websites so linking to
a high
domain authority website for example
having a link on wikipedia
that points back to our web page creates
high domain authority for us
and it helps drive traffic so some of
the other benefits of off-page seo
are credibility so if we're linking from
wikipedia
to our webpage it does create
credibility for us it also helps us
increase our page rank
so remember that external linking helps
build domain authority
helps build credibility trustworthiness
and it's going to in turn help us rank
for that particular page
and then certainly not last having a
good off-page seo link building strategy
increases our brand awareness because if
we're on other high
authority websites wikipedia or say a
social platform
it's going to increase our brand
awareness and increasing our brand
awareness
increases our trustworthiness and so if
somebody is looking to say
become a digital marketing specialist
then likely instead of typing in
digital marketing specialist on google
they may type in our brand name in this
case simply learn
and so these are all the benefits to off
page seo
so it's nothing more than having
links on other websites that are
pointing back to ours
and again there's lots of benefits it's
drives helps drive
traffic and increases our authority so
those are things that we want to take
advantage of
when we want to rank and the key behind
off-page seo or link building is always
going to be
content so from an on-page seo
perspective
having quality content allows that
content to be
optimized for relevant keyword and
ranked but also
from an off-page seo strategy having
high quality content allows us to have
other sites and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a website it could be a
social platform or can be another
blogging platform or blogging website
linked back to ours why because the
content is original it's natural
it's well structured it reads well and
so that's the whole idea behind
off page you can't have links on other
websites if you don't have quality
content
so one of the ideas behind off page seo
is not only do you want to create good
content but you probably want to
spend a lot of time or a bit of time on
others websites so remember the example
i used earlier in this presentation
about
having an ice cream blog and ice cream
recipes well it probably wouldn't be a
bad idea
to say spend some time on other blogs
related to
desserts related to cakes related to
food in general
related to vegetables or other items
that
people could link from so the whole idea
is
understanding who else is out there who
has relevant content
that you could share so you could share
your content with them they can share
their content with you
and generally that's how it works
naturally anyway in the
web sphere if somebody likes your
content they're going to link to it
they don't necessarily have to wait for
you to ask them but
it might not be a bad idea to understand
who else is out there that has content
similar to yours
so that you can you know get a link on
that particular website or blog post
and so some other ideas behind having
external links pointing back to your
website is social media
so social media is not just facebook or
twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core
there's medium there's all sorts of
content generated websites like reddit
so the list goes on and on you just need
to find what's relevant
for your content if it's relevant for
your content
then it's worth putting or trying to get
the external link
on that social media platform and then
again going back to my ice cream blog
recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog
that you want to have an external link
on there's nothing wrong with reaching
out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant
then why not it's only going to help
your end user experience
if you add somebody who has a say a blog
about
cakes having their link on your blog
post
so there's nothing wrong with it because
it also adds to the user experience
and if you're gonna ask somebody to put
an external link on theirs
you might want to be open-minded and
make sure that you're
are able and willing to put an external
link on your blog post or website
pointing to their content that's how the
web works
especially if the contents of quality
relevant
and of good nature so i want to thank
you for joining me today
i look forward to seeing you on other
uh simply learn presentations so thank
you for your time
and for more information please feel
free to visit
simplylearn.com thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here